[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat place aujourd'hui à
l'audition de marie-laure denis marie
leur donniez la présidente de la cnil la
commission nationale de l'informatique
et des libertés et elle s'est exprimée
devant les sénateurs de la commission
des lois
autour du projet d'application stop
qu'ovide annoncé il ya quelques jours
par olivier ferrand le ministre de la
santé ainsi que cédric au le secrétaire
d'état chargé du numérique cette
application doit permettre au moment du
des confirmands aux français qui
auraient installer cette application de
savoir si l'on croisé ou non une
personne qui a le qu'ovide 19 cela
suscite de nombreuses inquiétudes du
côté de la commission des lois ici au
sénat notamment en matière de libertés
individuelles
le gouvernement a tenté de rassurer se
projette en open source et les européens
il ne se fait que sur la base du
volontariat
devant les sénateurs marie laure denis a
pointé l les limites en matière
d'efficacité d'un tel projet en effet il
faudrait pour que cela soit efficace que
60% de la population et télécharger
cette application et cela pose bien des
difficultés entre les zones blanches en
france la fracture numérique
tout le monde ne sait pas télécharger
une application et enfin noter que
seulement 44 % des plus de 70 ans
dispose aujourd'hui d'un smartphone en
france
retour donc à l'audition de marie laure
denis nous avons souhaité vous
auditionné pour y voir plus clair sur la
question du stop qu'ovide puisque cette
ati qu'il est convenu d'appeler c'est à
dire une application qui permettrait à
chaque français au moment du des
confirmands d'être
informés rétrospectivement de personnes
qui auraient pu l'approcher ou dont ils
auraient pu s'approcher dans la journée
et qui seraient contaminées par le virus
du coc vide 19 un débat public s'est
engagé sur cette question la commission
nationale de l'informatique et des
libertés que vous présidez évidemment
aux premières loges
il s'agit d'abord pour vous de vous
assurer de non seulement de l'efficacité
d'un tel dispositif s'il venait à être
mis en place mais du respect des
dispositions législatives ainsi que du
règlement général pour la protection des
données que nous avons transposé il me
semble t'il il ya 18 mois dans la loi
française pour la partie de ce règlement
qui relève du parlement
ce dispositif ne peut évidemment être
envisagé que s'il est efficace et il ne
peut être efficace que s'il est
massivement utilisé mais s'il est
massivement utilisé ou plutôt pour qu'il
le soit il faudra bien qu'un minimum
d'incitation ou de pédagogie se
développe ce qui risque de poser la
question du volontariat reposant sur le
consentement libre et éclairé un
employeur vouloir que tous ses salariés
et l'application pour permettre la
reprise du travail salarié peut
souhaiter vivement être autorisé à
sortir de chez lui et si on lui dit que
le déconfinement passe par l'utilisation
de l'application son consentement sera
vont moins libre à l'évidence
donc ce sont des questions que nous
posons avec gravité évidemment car notre
rôle et nous l'avons montré lors de la
délibération du projet de loi qui est
devenue la loi d'urgence sanitaire c'est
bien sûr de donner aux pouvoirs publics
les moyens d'être efficace dans la lutte
contre cette épidémie
mais c'est aussi que ces moyens soient
nécessaires bien proportionnées à
l'objectif poursuivi est que s'il doit y
avoir des restrictions aux libertés des
français elles soient dûment justifiée
et que ces restrictions soient bien
contrôler voilà donc un très vaste
chantier auquel vous devez
nécessairement concourir votre
institution autorité administrative
indépendante a évidemment un grand rôle
à jouer elle l'a prouvé dans sa dans son
histoire déjà longue puisqu'elle est en
place depuis 1978
elle est elle-même là pour défendre les
libertés et c'est sur c'est cet ensemble
de préoccupations que nous aimerions
vous entendre je suis accompagné de deux
collègues sénateurs qui vont plus
particulièrement se pencher sur ces
questions et sur des questions générales
de protection de la vie privée dans le
cadre du comité de suivi que la
commission des lois a mis en place pour
suivre l'état d'urgence sanitaire pour
ce qui nous concerne nous les autres
commissions du sénat se sont organisé
elle-même poursuivre les travaux qui
concernent des questions sociales les
questions économiques et les questions
sanitaires bien évidemment au premier
rang de nos préoccupations
monsieur watts blé et sénateurs
du département du nord et monsieur hervé
que vous connaissez bien puisqu'il est
également membre de la cnil et sénateur
de savoie de haute-savoie
c'est ce que je disais monsieur le
sénateur madame denis vous avez donc la
parole non mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs mesdames et messieurs je vous
remercie d'auditionner la cnil dans le
cadre de vos travaux de suivi de la
crise sanitaire sans précédent que nous
que nous traversons pour cette audition
je suis accompagné de louis dutheillet
de lamothe notre nouveau secrétaire
général qui a pris ses fonctions hier et
qui est en visio conférence et de
gwendal le grand le secrétaire général
adjoint de la cnil qui est de la
commission des lois sont également
reliée à nous par visioconférence et ils
vous poseront bien sûr des questions
tout à l'heure tout à fait tout à fait
monsieur le président je voudrais avoir
une pensée quand même en ces moments
extrêmement difficiles avant de débuter
cette audition pour tous ceux d'abord
qui sont dans la souffrance est dans la
détresse pour tous ceux qui accompagnent
au jour le jour qui sont engagés
quotidiennement sur le terrain pour
accompagner les victimes
pour accompagner la population et si je
le rappelle en préambule c'est parce que
toutes nos réflexions toutes nos
décisions ne peuvent être prises qu'à
l'aune de ce contexte
avant d'entrer dans le vif du sujet du
recours au traçage au suivi numérique
des personnes je souhaiterais dire
quelques mots si vous m'y autorise et
des enjeux enfin généraux de protection
des données en cette période très
particulière
tout d'abord la continuité d'activité
repose aujourd'hui sur des outils
numériques consommateurs en données
personnelles et qui sont massivement
utilisé qu'il s'agisse de la
télémédecine du télétravail des cours à
distance pour les élèves et
même si ça n'est pas le coeur de cette
audition je voulais en tout cas vous
assurer que la cnil joue tout son rôle
d'accompagnement à l'égard des
particuliers des entreprises des
organismes des pouvoirs publics pour
délivrer des conseils très pratiques
liés à la cybersécurité par exemple que
ce soit pour les salariés ou les
employeurs à propos du recours au
télétravail ou des conseils en matière
de recours à la vision conférence que
nous sommes en train de faire ou
d'accompagnement d'outils pédagogiques
d'autre part nous sommes très impliqués
également en ce qui concerne les études
les recherches en matière de santé qui
naturellement utilise des données
personnelles la cnil a mis en place une
procédure accélérée d'instruction
concernant les traitements à des fins de
recherche et a déjà délivré depuis le
début de la crise une vingtaine
d'autorisation à des acteurs comme
l'ap-hp l'inserm l'institut pasteur
différents chu sê étude vise par exemple
à tester des traitements à étudier les
facteurs de mortalité des personnes
âgées a analysé l'évolution des formes
graves de l'infection et la majorité des
projets d'ailleurs peuvent être mises en
oeuvre sans autorisation dès lors qu'ils
sont conformes à une méthodologie de
référence élaboré par la cnil il suffit
alors de faire une simple déclaration à
la cnil
par ailleurs voudrais m'arrêter un
instant sur les actions de la cnil en
lien avec les collectivités
territoriales auxquelles le sénat est
particulièrement attaché la cnil a pris
contact très rapidement avec les trois
principaux niveaux de collectivités
territoriales représenté par régions de
france l'assemblée des départements de
france et l'association des maires de
france afin de faire connaître aux élus
de terrain sa disponibilité pour
répondre aux questions se rapportant à
la gestion de la crise sanitaire
la cnil a reçu des demandes des
collectivités essentiellement des
communes d'ailleurs qui se posent des
questions très concrètes sur les
conditions dans lesquelles les données
qu'elles détiennent peuvent être
utilisés pour tous chers au mieux les
populations afin de leur porter
assistance en particulier s'agissant des
personnes les plus vulnérables
ces demandes sont notamment relatives
aux registres communaux d' alerte et
d'information des populations
souvenez qu'ils ont dû être créé pas
qu'ils ont été créée par une loi
d'ailleurs de juin 2004 après la
canicule de l'été 2003 c'est registre
recense les personnes les plus fragiles
notamment en raison de leur âge ou du
handicap afin de faciliter leur
assistance en cas de risques
exceptionnels
le législateur avait souhaité que cergy
soit constitué sur la base du
volontariat et la cnil veille a rappelé
et on vient de publier une fiche
pratique sur notre site les règles
applicables à la tenue de ces
dispositifs qui ne peuvent en
particulier pas conduire à la
constitution de ce qu'on pourrait
appeler avec beaucoup de guillemets de
fichiers de population et les élus
locaux nous ont d'ailleurs saisi de
demandes pendantes à l'utilisation
d'autres fichiers pour aider leur
population et tout en rappelant le cadre
légal applicable la cnil ses forces dans
ses réponses de trouver des solutions
aux problèmes posés dans un esprit le
plus constructif et le plus est dans
possible j'en viens à la question qui a
justifié plus particulièrement cette
demande d'audition qui est donc relative
au suivi numérique individualisé des
personnes afin de déterminer si une
personne a été exposée au co vie de 19
et qui est au coeur comme vous l'avez
rappelé monsieur le président du débat
public
le collège de la cnil à deux convictions
sur ces outils la première sur laquelle
je voudrais particulièrement insisté
c'est que les textes qui protègent les
données personnelles ne s'oppose pas à
la mise en oeuvre de solutions de suivi
numérique individualisé pour la
protection ou non d'ailleurs pour la
protection de la santé publique
ces textes imposent essentiellement de
prévoir des garanties adaptées
d'autant plus forte que les technologies
sont intrusive mettre en avant un cadre
respectueux de la vie privée et des
données personnelles est tout à fait
nécessaire pour asseoir la confiance
créer les conditions d'une acceptabilité
sociale d'une technique potentiellement
intrusive et garantir la sécurité de son
utilisation
j'insiste parce qu'en fait il n'y a pas
à se demander s'il faut s'affranchir du
cadre ou prendre des libertés avec celui
ci parce que le cadre juridique que
l'europe et la france se sont donné
qu'on porte en lui-même les solutions
permettant de répondre à la situation
la deuxième conviction du collège de
lacnic dont je souhaitais vous faire
part concerne le recours aux
technologies numériques
il faut se garder de penser qu'une
application va tout résoudre
même si les nouvelles technologies
peuvent contribuer à une sortie
sécurisée du confinement dans le cadre
d'une stratégie sanitaire plus que plus
globale j'appelle régulièrement la
vigilance contre ce qu'on appelle un peu
dans notre jargon le solutionner une
technologique
il faut certes explorer à fond les
opportunités des technologies mais aussi
leurs limites intrinsèques et le risque
pour les droits des personnes
et d'ailleurs ça serait même dangereux
de penser qu'une application de ce type
enfin dangereux en quelque sorte ou en
tout cas pas tout à fait exact de penser
qu'une application de ce type pourraient
tout résoudre
parce que ça pourrait nous faire aussi
baissé la garde par rapport à la
nécessité des gestes barrières des ports
des masques des nécessités de se faire
tester quand on a des symptômes et puis
aussi disons le ça ne prend pas en
compte par la par nature par la force
des choses les cas asymptomatiques dont
je lis fut pas et allez personnes
beaucoup plus qualifiés que moi pour le
dire qu'elles peuvent représenter
jusqu'à 30% des personnes contaminées
donc si la technologie traitement des
données peuvent être d'un grand secours
dans la gestion de cette crise il est
aujourd'hui difficile faute de recul
suffisant d'évaluer les bénéfices
effectif qui pourrait être tiré de
l'utilisation de tels dispositifs
d'autant plus que les usages peuvent
varier
tant au niveau des données collectées
que des finalités poursuivies alors
c'est dans cette optique que la cnil
s'entoure d'une double expertise la
première expertise elle est naturelle
pour nous c'est notre coeur de métier
c'est nous donner les moyens de
connaître et de comprendre d'un point de
vue technique
l'ensemble des dispositifs utilisés des
projets envisager des solutions
imaginées dans le monde d'ailleurs pour
lutter contre la pandémie et nos
ingénieurs et nos juristes et les autres
experts sont au contact des innovateurs
de nos homologues et réalise une veille
continue depuis la mi mars la seconde
expertise avait peut-être moins
naturel pour la cnil mais elle est
indispensable dans ce contexte c'est la
compréhension de l'intérêt de santé
publique de telle ou telle solution
envisagée pour être en mesure ou être
capable d'en mesurer la nécessité la
proportionnalité et la pertinence en ce
qui concerne les traitements de données
mise en oeuvre c'est ainsi que le
collège de la cnil a auditionné il ya
exactement quinze jours le président du
conseil scientifique le professeur jean
françois delfraissy que vous recevez je
crois vous additionnez juste après moi
je n'évoquerai devant vous ce matin les
exemples étrangers que pour dégager des
grandes tendances en matière
d'utilisation des données les
technologies d'abord je voudrais attirer
l'attention sur le fait qu'il faut être
prudent dès qu'on fait des comparaisons
étrangères et qu'on compare des
dispositifs de suivi numérique des
personnes parce qu on fait abstraction
bien souvent des particularismes des
cultures locales et bien souvent aussi
des modalités de mise en oeuvre des
technologies multiples recours à des
caméras thermiques de la reconnaissance
faciale l'utilisation de drones la
collecte d'informations sur les médias
sociaux etc
mais si on s'attache plus
particulièrement à ce qu'on appelle le
suivi des contacts ou le contact racing
ce qui est différent du tracking qui en
quelque sorte utilise des données de
géolocalisation beaucoup plus précise
avec un suivi continu et précis des
personnes
donc je concentrerai mon propos sur le
contact racing c'est à dire les
technologies qui se fonde sur l'analyse
des données de localisation des
individus pour dégager peut-être trois
types de finalités différentes la
première finalité c'est d'utiliser ces
données pour pouvoir cartographier en
quelque sorte la propagation du virus
prédire les zones à risque et donc aider
les autorités à planifier les besoins
sanitaires
c'est une finalité de modélisation
d'anticipation est donc en quelque sorte
d'observation
qui se font sur l'utilisation de données
suffisamment agrégées pour qu'elle soit
anonymisée et à partir du moment où
elles sont suffisamment agrégées pour
être anonymisées ce ne sont pas des
données personnelles ce sont plus des
données personnelles
voilà ça c'est un point que je
souhaitais précisé après la 2e finalité
c'est des données de localisation qui
sont utilisés pour faire respecter les
mesures prises par les gouvernements et
notamment les consignes de distanciation
sociale ou encore les obligations de
confinement est donc là la finalité
c'est une finalité de contrôle qui bien
souvent se base sur des données de
géolocalisation de chez ps que tout le
monde connaît qui permet effectivement
de savoir de façon très précise et
continue
quel est le parcours d'une personne
enfin certains pays utilisent les
données pour faire du suivi de contact
c'est-à-dire retrouver les contacts des
personnes potentiellement exposées pour
les avertir et éventuellement les
invitées à se faire dépister
pour ce faire il ya plusieurs modalités
certains pays vont jusqu à recouper ces
données de localisation avec d'autres
données des données bancaires des
données sur les tests et les diagnostics
des données de détenus par les douanes
et l'immigration pour reconstituer les
antécédents de voyage par exemple et
donc la finalité de ce type
d'application c'est une finalité
d'information et/ou de contrôle mais en
tout cas d'informations pour atteindre
ces trois objectifs à des degrés divers
on peut distinguer schématiquement deux
séries de technique
la localisation individuelle et la
localisation collective la première
tendance
la localisation individuelle on vous en
avait beaucoup entendu parler à propos
de l'asie du moyen-orient un peu aussi
en europe ce sont des dispositifs qui
sont variables par exemple en corée du
sud
ils ces dispositifs mais l'information
est le contrôle des données de
géolocalisation recoupe avec d'autres
données la possibilité pour le
gouvernement d'ordonner à des personnes
en quarantaine d'installer une
application pour respecter le vérifier
le respect du confinement et ses
différents par exemple à singapour avec
un dispositif fondé sur le volontariat
est une technologie bluetooth c'est une
application qui vise à identifier les
personnes potentiellement exposées à
identifier qui doit être testé
la seconde tendance c'est celle de la
localisation collective qui a été mise
en oeuvre par un certain nombre de pays
européens des données collectives italie
autriche allemagne
en france vous avez entendu parler avec
orange par exemple de l'utilisation de
données anonymisées en partenariat avec
l'inserm ou si la même approche qui a
été développée par sfr par exemple avec
l'inria et l'ap-hp
c'est ce à quoi je faisais référence
tout à l'heure c'est des données
suffisamment agrégées pour être
anonymisées et cartographier la
propagation de l'épidémie
alors après ce rapide tour d'horizon des
solutions constater qu'elle première
analyse informatique et libertés en
tirer en tout cas le cadre juridique
français et européens il a un objectif
qu un souci c'est de garantir la
maîtrise maximale des personnes sur
leurs données
alors quel est le cadre juridique vous
vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le
président dans votre temps votre propos
introductif plusieurs tests sont
applicables le premier c'est une
directive de 2002 sur la protection de
la vie privée dans les communications
électroniques c'est la directive deee
privacy qui pose un cadre très strict
on peut déduire de ces articles 5 et 9
que sauf anonymisation le traitement des
données de localisation est soumis au
consentement donc à l'accord de
l'utilisateur
il est possible de déroger au
consentement par le texte dit je cite
des mesures législatives
fin de citation des états membres que
dans certaines hypothèses limitativement
énumérées à l'article 15 de ces
directives parmi lesquels figurent la
sécurité publique entendu largement
susceptible de couvrir cette situation
en france compte tenu de fin de la
conjugaison entre ce texte et l'article
34 de notre constitution que vous
connaissez mieux que quiconque et qui
réserve à la loi de fixer les règles
concernant les garanties fondamentales
accordées aux citoyens pour l'exercice
des libertés publiques
il faudrait
vraisemblablement une loi pour mobiliser
ces exceptions dans l'hypothèse donc où
il n'y aurait pas d'accord de
l'utilisateur de l'application de suivi
ça c'est le premier texte la directive
hypra gossip qui devraient être
combinées donc avec l'article 34 de la
constitution deuxième texte celui auquel
vous avez fait allusion monsieur le
président référence c'est le règlement
général sur la protection des données
qui a été effectivement introduit enfin
dans notre droit en mai 2018 qui est
applicable à tout traitement de données
personnelles notamment de contact racing
et qui offre lui aussi un cadre
juridique en tout cas qui prévoit en
tout cas lui aussi un cadre juridique
exigeant il s'applique ses exigences en
tout cas sont de trois ordres
la première c'est que tout traitement de
données doit avoir une base légale pour
les dispositifs dont nous parlons un
consentement et c'est le seul texte que
je suis très très précisément tel que
prévu au petit à petit b du petit 1 de
l'article 6 du rgp des vous promets que
ce sera la seule citation de ce type un
consentement donc tel que prévu dans ce
texte est la base légale qui vient
immédiatement à l'esprit le hergé en
prévoit d'autres tels que la mission
d'intérêt public de l'organisme qui
traite des données ou dans certains cas
particulier la sauvegarde des intérêts
vitaux des personnes
concrètement il faut qu'ils y est soit
du volontariat soit un texte qui en
france devrait être loi c'est ça un peu
le cadre juridique en tout cas en ce qui
concerne la base légale
le deuxième la deuxième exigence du rgp
des concerne plus spécifiquement le
traitement des données de santé
susceptibles d'être collectés dans de
nombreux dispositifs mis en oeuvre pour
générer pour gérer la crise sanitaire le
principe en droit de la protection des
données c'est que l'utilisation des
données de santé le traitement des
descentes et est interdite naturellement
il ya des exceptions
parmi ces exceptions figure l'intérêt
public dans le domaine de la santé
publique les nécessités de la prise en
charge sanitaire le consentement de la
personne
la sauvegarde des intérêts vitaux et la
recherche peut également constituer une
autre exception au principe du
consentement
la troisième exigence du rgp des vous le
savez c'est l'application de toute une
série de principes de fonds et de
garanties que les états doivent
respecter même lorsqu'ils ont des
raisons légitimes de limiter certains
droits ou certaines obligations
ces principes se sont ceux de
proportionnalité la sécurité par exemple
et je pourrais les détails et plus de
façon plus exhaustive
l'objectif de ces règles il est clair
c'est de maximiser la maîtrise des
personnes sur leurs données
alors au regard de ce cadre juridique
double dip réussir gp des jeux peut
synthétiser le faisceau de
recommandations que le collège de la
cnil pourrait émettre à ce stade non pas
sur un projet en particulier mais sur la
problématique sur le questionnement au
delà de la nécessité de disposer d'un
fondement juridique adéquat pour traiter
les données quels sont les principes à
respecter
tout d'abord il est très important de
définir et de préciser les finalités du
traitement qu'on met en oeuvre on doit
exact on doit savoir exactement pourquoi
pour quelle finalité pour quels
objectifs on en oeuvre ce traitement à
partir de quand et est d'ailleurs aussi
se permettra de déterminer quand on n'y
aura plus recours une fois posé
l'objectif poursuivi il faudra pouvoir
exposer pourquoi le recours aux données
de localisation et ses interactions est
adéquat nécessaire proportionnée adéquat
il faut que l'instrument mise en place
apparaissent réellement utiles pour
traiter la crise sanitaire nécessaire
l'utilisation de telles données ne doit
pas être une solution de confort il faut
réellement qu'on en ait besoin pour
contribuer à juguler la crise et qu'il
n'y a pas d'alternative efficace même
combiner les unes avec les autres
proportionnée comme l'a rappelé le
comité européen de la protection des
données qui réunit des cnil européennes
les solutions les plus intrusive doivent
toujours être privilégiée en ce qui
concerne la proportionnelle et les moins
instruits ou excusez moi c'est un
je vous remercie de l'avoir fait en
sorte qu'ils me causer un préjudice
disproportionnée la proportionnalité
justement devrait aussi être évaluée au
regard du caractère temporaire
uniquement liées à la gestion de la
crise de tout dispositif envisagé
c'est un point essentiel il faut
vraiment que cette application si elle
voit le jour ne soit pas que sa durée de
vie n'excède pas la durée qui est
nécessaire au traitement de la crise
sanitaire et ça veut dire aussi qu'il
faut pouvoir s'assurer de la destruction
de la suppression des données dès que
c'est nécessaire donc une durée limitée
une sorte de date de péremption une
sorte de d'obsolescence programmée plus
la suppression des données en tout cas
de la plupart d'entre elles même si on
peut imaginer que de façon anonymisées
certaines données soient conservées à
des fins de recherche pour une durée
limitée etc
il faut enfin respecter le principe de
minimisation des données traitées
utiliser que les données qui sont
nécessaires le moins d'informations
nominatives possible ou alors associer
ces données à un identifiant unique
généré lors de l'installation de
l'application par exemple
donc l'idée c'est de concevoir des
dispositifs qui permettent encore une
fois d'assurer une maîtrise des
personnes sur leurs données
donc je reviens pas sur la démarche
volontaire qu'il faut avoir au regard
[Musique]
2 vous avez fait aussi référence
monsieur le président au caractère au
consentement et donc il est
effectivement très important que ce
consentement il soit éclairé c'est à
dire que les utilisateurs de cette
application et toutes les informations
nécessaires pour faire leur choix en
connaissance de cause que le refus de
consentir n'expose pas la personne a des
conséquences négatives
j insiste parce que les comparaisons
internationales montrent que le
volontariat a parfois des contreparties
qui en limitent la liberté
pour dire les choses crûment si le refus
de télécharger l'application est
d'utiliser réduit votre faculté de
déplacement ou vos libertés civiles ou
si elle vous expose à un régime de
contrôle le consentement n'est pas
considérée comme libre en matière de
données personnelles y compris si
d'autres bases légales venait à être
mobilisé un véritable volontariat est la
meilleure garantie du respect des
principes du rgp d il faut enfin c'est
un peu plus technique il pourrait y
revenir si vous le souhaitez
ultérieurement privilégié évidemment le
stockage des données en local sur le
terminal de l'utilisateur
d'une manière générale comme c'est le
dispositif qui semble être envisagée en
france il voit le jour les applications
qui s'appuie sur des données bluetooth
sont chiffrés directement sur le
téléphone sous le contrôle de
l'utilisateur apporte davantage de
garanties que celles qui s'appuient sur
un suivi géolocaliser gps des personnes
qui permettent un traçage continue et y
précis de ces personnes de ce point de
vue les rôles de la clean cnil et de
l'ansea l'agencé nationale de sécurité
des systèmes d'information se complètent
parfaitement et nous travaillons en
étroite coopération chacun dans notre
champ de compétence parce que la cnil
est aussi un acteur à part entière de la
cybersécurité est pleinement engagé dans
la défense de la souveraineté européenne
en résumé si un suivi individualisé des
personnes étaient mises en oeuvre
il faudrait d'abord à droit constant
qu'il soit sûr basé sur le volontariat
pour une durée limitée
je ne reviens pas sur l'hypothèse d'une
application qui serait obligatoire
puisque le président de la république
lundi soir dans son allocution l'a exclu
je voudrais juste dire un mot si vous me
permettez du niveau européen en matière
de protection des données qui est
naturellement le niveau pertinent de
réflexion voire de réaction
le comité européen des données cette
réunion très intégré sedif est il très
intégré des cnil européennes joue tout
son rôle dès le 19 mars le cep des abats
publier un communiquer avec une première
grille d analyse nous avons des points
de contact dont chaque autorité nous
nous réunissons toutes les semaines au
lieu de tous les mois et trois priorités
ont été dégagées par le cep des dont la
première est précisément l'élaboration
d'orientations concernant l'utilisation
des données de localisation et
d'anonymisation et l'anonymisation des
données etc la cnil qui au sein du cep
des avec naturellement le concours
d'autres homologues pilotera cette
réflexion sur l'utilisation des données
de localisation et l'anonymisation des
données par les cnil européennes
nous avons déjà transmis des éléments de
réflexion à la commission européenne qui
doit publier aujourd'hui un certain
nombre de faits une sorte de boîte à
outils si j'ai bien compris sur sur sur
le sujet et nous mêmes probablement dès
la semaine prochaine ou au plus tard
dans une dizaine de jours fin de nous
mêmes le comité européen de la
protection des données avec une forte
implication de la cnil publiera des
lignes directrices des recommandations
en tout cas sa réflexion sur sur le
sujet sachant que les deux autres
priorités du cpdc l'utilisation des
données de santé et le télétravail est
donc je sais c'est très délicat de
conclure une audition comme celle ci est
d'apporter des réponses précises
par rapport à l'éventuelle mise en place
d'un dispositif dont on ne connaît pas
encore tous les contours
s'il voit le jour le collège de la cnil
est conscient de l'importance de l'enjeu
de l'urgence qu'il ya à conjuguer
efficacité sanitaires et protection des
données
si j'ai une conviction c'est que ces
deux termes sont liés ou ces deux
expressions sont liés efficacité
sanitaires et protection des données
parce que ça n'est que par leurs
combinaisons qui pourra y avoir la
confiance suffisante
indissociable du respect de la vie
privée pour que ce dispositif comme vous
le disiez monsieur le président dans
votre propos introductif puis se
rencontrer une adhésion suffisamment
massive de nos concitoyens pour être
efficace et la tenue d'un débat
parlementaire permettra certainement
d'apporter de la transparence et des
informations sur ce sujet et contribuera
à assurément à bâtir ce cadre de
confiance
en tout cas la cnil assure toutes ses
missions sa mission d'accompagnement et
si ce dispositif voit le jour assurera
la plaine effectivité de sa mission de
contrôle
merci monsieur le président merci
beaucoup
madame la présidente le mot de la fin de
votre intervention c'est la nécessité de
bâtir un cadre de confiance et c'est
toute la question 1 que
nous avons à discuter avec vous il ya
deux points sur lequel je voudrais
revenir avant de céder la parole à mes
collègues
le premier c'est parmi vos
recommandations
l'exigence que le recours à un tel
dispositif soit adéquate et j'avais vous
dit ça signifie utile pourriez-vous nous
dire qu'elles sont de votre point de vue
à ce stade de la réflexion de la cnil
les conditions auxquelles un tel
dispositif vous paraît très adéquat
il s'agit vraiment de son efficacité
même si on déborde sur des exigences de
fonds mais c'est le cas dans tous les
traitements spécifiques que vous avez à
examiner c'est à dire ces exigences
c'est la sécurité sanitaire
vous avez bien mentionné le fait que la
mise en oeuvre d'un tel dispositif
n'était recommandable que si ils étaient
adéquates
alors quelles conditions de serait-il
est le deuxième point sur lequel je
voulais revenir et je les mentionnaient
en ouvrant cette audition et c'est celui
du volontariat du consentement libre et
éclairé
je pense que nos travaux et des travaux
du gouvernement les travaux du conseil
scientifique beaucoup d'autres
réflexions qui sont aujourd'hui public
contribue à éclairer l'éventuelle
concept consentement à l'utilisation du
dispositif mais en vain il faut quelque
chose de plus que une ambiance générale
d'information et avez vous dit il ne
faut pas pour que le consentement soit
libre et c'est l'autre dimension libre
et éclairé que le refus de consentir
expose les personnes à des contreparties
négative par exemple
si le refus consentir exposé l'individu
à une réduction de sa liberté d'aller et
venir
évidemment il y à un biais dans la
liberté du consentement est ce que vous
pouvez aller un peu plus loin dans la
réflexion de ce qui permettrait
d'assurer cette liberté étant entendu
que healy à la liberté formelle et la
liberté réelle
quelle est la liberté du salarié qui
aspirent à reprendre son travail a
retrouvé sa pleine rémunération
vis-à-vis de l'employeur qui lui
demanderaient de de prendre
l'application pour des motifs d'ailleurs
tout à fait légitime de sécurité
sanitaire du travail collectif voilà les
deux questions que je voulais essayer
d'approfondir un peu avec vous merci de
d'y répondre
en ce qui concerne le caractère adéquat
du dispositif qui serait envisagée pour
qu'il soit utile d'abord je prendrai un
certain nombre de précautions oratoires
parce que naturellement il faut pouvoir
apprécier cette utilité par rapport à un
contexte sanitaire dont on sait bien que
la vérité du jour n'est pas
nécessairement celle du lendemain
nous ne sommes pas des spécialistes de
la santé publique
et c'est bien la raison pour laquelle
avec tout et beaucoup d'humilité
nous nous essayons d'appréhender ce
champ est comme vous également en en
ayant recours à des expertises pour que
ce ce dispositif soit utile il ya des
quoi indépendamment de la question de
savoir quel pourcentage de la population
effectivement oui il couvrirait
il couvrirait sachant qu' il y à déjà
par nature 25% des français qui n'ont
pas de d'ordiphones comme on dit en
français permettant de télécharger une
application et je pense et ce taux est
d'autant plus élevée chez les personnes
âgées puisque chez les personnes de plus
de 70 ans
il n'ya que 44 % de ces personnes qui
ont un smartphone contre 98 % des 18-25
ans et indépendamment de cette question
de l'équipement numérique des français
il y à aussi il faut je pense que ça
résout pas tout il ya aussi la question
même pour ceux qui ont des smartphones
de la compétence numérique ya un certain
nombre de personnes qui ont un ordiphone
mais qui ne sont pas nécessairement à
même de télécharger une application de
s'enrôler dans l'application de la
paramétrer si c'est nécessaire et de
l'utiliser et j'ajoute à ça et je pense
qu'au sénat je sais en tant qu ancien
membre de l'arcep que vous y êtes très
attaché il y à là haut tout cas très
soucieux et aussi la question des zones
blanches
voilà et de la capacité à utiliser par
les réseaux une application de ce type
sur ce sujet précis
la seule étude que nous avons lu et je
la cite avec beaucoup de prudence
c'est une étude de l'université d'oxford
qui dit qu'il faudrait que une
application de ce type puisse couvrir 60
% de la population pour être efficace
cela dit je le dis avec beaucoup de
prudence beaucoup de nuances parce que
deux je crois comprendre
de la façon dont tu as été réalisé cette
étude qu'elle ne prend pas en compte
alors que c'est absolument indispensable
sa combinaison
la combinaison d'un tel dispositif avec
l'utilisation de réponse sanitaire qui
sont les réponses essentielles encore
une fois qu'ils doivent être privilégiés
les gestes barrière plus de tests plus
de masques alors ensuite sur l'utilité
ou ce qui pourrait réduire en quelque
sorte l'efficacité d'un tel dispositif
puisque le dispositif mettant en face à
face en quelque sorte où on rapports ou
en relation des personnes qui auraient
été contaminées avec des personnes qui
auraient été exposées avec cette
personne contaminée qu'en est il des
personnes qui ont été contaminées kèlè
kèlè aussi la proportion dans les tests
sérologiques qui sont utilisées des faux
positifs des faux négatifs l'a encore
vue d'une paix sociale et de la santé
publique et je me garderai bien de
répondre mais ce que je lis et que ça
peut c'est plutôt plusieurs dizaines de
pourcents le cas échéant et
qu'en est-il aussi des personnes qui
sont porteuses du virus mais qui ne
présentent pas de symptômes et qui donc
n'ont pas de raison de se déclarer dans
l'application comme étant puisqu'elles
sont asymptomatiques comme étant
atteintes du virus
et puis pour les personnes exposées ou
supposément exposées tout dépend aussi
du paramétrage de l'application du
dispositif
quelle est la distance qui est prise en
compte
quelle est la durée de contact qui est
prise en compte dans ce qu'on a vu à
singapour auquel se réfère beaucoup les
médias et qui semble être
l'exemple le plus proche de ce qui
serait envisagée pour la france du
bluetooth du volontariat
c'était une distance de moins de deux
mètres pour une exposition de trente
minutes de moins de 30 minutes d'une
trentaine de minutes alors que je vois
que ce qui est en train ce à quoi est en
train de réfléchir par exemple à la nhs
le service de santé britannique
c'est la même distance mais pour 15
minutes on voit que les paramètres
peuvent varier et à partir de là aussi
pour parler concrètement est ce qu'il ya
des différences entre le fait de passer
devant la caissière de son supermarché
qui a un masque et par laquelle vous
êtes séparés avec une pas par une vis de
laquelle vous êtes séparés par une vitre
ou dette dans une rame de métro ou dans
un supermarché ou dans certains dans
certaines communes d'île de france il ya
un supermarché pour 20000 habitants en
termes de concentration population
quelles sont les conséquences en matière
de résultats
de l'application qui seraient mises en
place sur le nombre de cas voilà il ya
quand même tout un nombre de paramètres
qui mérite en tout cas d'être précisée
pour pouvoir apprécier le caractère
adéquat monsieur le président de cette
application
alors en ce qui concerne le point
essentiel effectivement du consentement
pour s'assurer qu'ils soient réellement
libre et éclairé d'abord il faut
naturellement qu'il y ait une
information pour qu'il faut a éclairé
qui soit réellement apporter à
l'utilisateur alors cette information ça
ça peut être l'information générale des
médias des politiques publiques mais
sait il doit nécessairement y avoir une
information plus précise individualisé
lorsqu'on télécharge l'application qui
permet concrètement de savoir quelles
données sont utilisées par qui avec
quelles finalités avec qui elles sont
partagées et pour combien de temps ça ça
et il faut vraiment rentrer dans les
détails
nous on est très soucieux à la cnil
d'une façon générale même indépendamment
de ce contexte de veiller à ce qu'il n'y
ait pas de case précochée par exemple de
consentement qui est vraiment la
manifestation d'un acte clair et positif
maintenant donc ça c'est
je dis pas que c'est la théorie parce
que c'est ce que nous ont très
concrètement en pratique mais vous avez
fort opportunément souligné qu'il peut y
avoir une sorte de pression sociale en
quelque sorte qui peut s'exercer
indépendamment de ces considérations
plus juridique ou plus techniques qui
consisterait à ne pas pouvoir accéder à
un lieu à un travail à un cercle social
si on n'a pas téléchargé l'application
et ça il faut absolument lutter contre
ça d'abord encore une fois je crois
qu'il faut vraiment popularisé l'idée
que cette application ne résout pas
quelle que soit son appellation esquissé
elle ne résout pas à elle seule en tout
cas elle ne résume pas et ne résout pas
la crise sanitaire que nous traversions
même si elle peut y contribuer en étant
un des éléments d'une réponse sanitaire
plus globale
et puis la cnil en tout état de cause
veillerai à ce que des plaintes puisse
être déposée auprès d'elle et soit
instruite au plus vite si été constaté
des comportements d'exclusion on l'a vu
au début de la crise sanitaire un
certain nombre d'employeurs ont exigé
par exemple que leurs salariés leurs
indics
leur température corporelle au jour le
jour avant de rentrer dans les bureaux
bas nous nous y sommes naturellement
fermement opposés nous avons publié des
recommandations sur notre site nous
avons traité les cas qui devait traiter
et la cnil encore une fois sur pour
s'assurer en tout cas du le recueil du
consentement libre et éclairé
procéderait certainement de la même
façon merci chère madame la présidente
je vais donner la parole à monsieur
waterblez ce qu'il veut bien
merci monsieur le président merci man de
nice allumé mon collègue hervé et nos
collègues qui sont en vie de conférence
j'avais trois questions mais une grande
partie a déjà été répondu sur la
question des questions du présent bah je
vais revenir un petit peu bombé sur son
caractère volontaire du recours à
l'application et vous avez répondu sur
le consentement libre et éclairé des
personnes en cas de très sagement terre
mais je n'insisterai sur la contrepartie
est ce qu'il est il possible et
souhaitable de prévoir des contreparties
qui serait pas bien sûr des contraintes
pour inciter nos concitoyens installé
épuisé une habitation de traçage parce
que c'est vrai qu'on ne peut porter un
contrainte mais si la panne associations
quelque part je suis pas sûr que tout le
monde le fera de façon très spontanée et
puis une réflexion qui sera plus globale
à leur tour au traçage des contacts est
destinée à briser bien sûr plus
efficacement et plus rapidement les
chaînes de communication
il faut bien sûr isoler les personnes
exposées à un risque en les faisant
tester pour qu'ils ne contaminent pas
d'autres personnes leur tournée c'est un
peu sur le skate le point que vous avez
assisté
cela suppose une approche plus que
salutaire très dimensionné il faudra
être prêt de façon unitaire pour ces
tests puisque aujourd'hui on est pas
en capacité de d'effectuer un nombre
important de test donc il faudra être
forcément très très près et je voudrais
pas que quelque part cette forme de
d'applications numériques soit comme la
berri très bien dit ainsi au lui
sionisme technologique c'est à dire que
sans test derrière à chaque fois en
lecture à quelqu'un bon alors qu'un
outil qu'il servira pas alors il ya deux
choses deux écueils déjà le nombre de
personnes qui vont mettre l'application
sur leur portable
jean réduit déjà une capacité le
problème de ne pas contraindre
effectivement ça réduit encore et puis
derrière c'est la vraie solution la
vraie réponse quels moyens avons nous
pour justement tester les gens fouillent
à mesure de leur prescription de mode
quand les découvrir voilà ce que je
voulais dire le rush classe mondiale au
président pour l'essentiel même la
présidence souligné que ça ne pouvait
prendre place que dans un ensemble de
dispositifs parce que comme le dit notre
collègue dany wattebled
à quoi servirait d'être informés sur le
fait qu'on a été en contact pendant un
temps suffisant avec quelqu'un porteurs
du virus
si ensuite on n'a pas accès massivement
à des tests de dépistage est sans doute
plusieurs fois parce que on ne peut pas
être certain qu au lendemain même d'une
telle rencontre un test de dépistage
soit efficace il peut donc y avoir non
seulement des faux négatifs mais aussi
des faux sécurité monsieur hervé merci
mais je présenterai ma présidente chers
collègues rapporteur donc chers
collègues
moi j'avais plusieurs plusieurs
observations d'abord une observation que
plusieurs questions
la première observation c'est sur la
compétence législative vous avez rappelé
le droit communautaire le droit interne
et la nécessité relative d'avoir recours
à un texte législatif haddock à supposer
qu'on aille sur les
l'application qui a été envisagée par le
président de la république mais je pense
que dans ce cadre là c'est bien l'euro
le rôle du parlement dans le cadre d'un
débat organisé et qui interviendrait ne
peut pas être le seul la seule
intervention du parlement je pense que
nous sommes en train de faire
aujourd'hui ce que la cnil fait
également dans ces travaux qui est
essentielle dans la préparation aux
cadres de confiance et aussi dans les
garanties qu'elle peut apporter au fur
et à mesure de la mise en oeuvre de
l'application une fois qu'elle sera
devenu opérationnel c'est quelque chose
qui est qui m'importe beaucoup parce que
on raisonne beaucoup de manière
abstraite avec des principes c'est
essentiel on est là d'ailleurs pour ça
mais on verra en compte en se
confrontant à la technique est la mise
en oeuvre réelle de la chose que
beaucoup d'autres questions vont venir
et parfois même vont venir par grappes
puisque elles vont engendrer des
questions la simple évocation de la
présidente de dés des tests de
température dans les entreprises
démontrent que la l'inventivité humaine
couplé par le bon sens où ce quelque
chose qui est évoqué comme tel ça donne
lieu phare parfois des as des choses
tout à fait tout à fait préoccupant
j'en viens donc aux questions qu'on
questions techniques et à la question du
bluetooth et des et des contraintes
est-ce que ce bluetooth qui présentent
moins de risques de sécurité et qui est
moins intrusif que la géolocalisation
est ce qu'il est ce qu'il est
suffisamment efficace quand même pour
pour répondre à ce qu'on lui demande
c'est à dire à pouvoir vraiment avoir
une forme de traces hing des contacts et
si l'on regarde un peu les exemples
étrangers notamment l'exemple coréen
on s'aperçoit que derrière l'application
elle-même télécharger sur un terminal
mobile
il ya une infrastructure humaines
considérables de gens qui sont là pour
interpréter et pour donner lieu
notamment à des appels téléphoniques
individualisé est ce que la commission
nationale informatique et libertés à une
réflexion sur la partie infrastructure
on va dire en back office à l'arrière
pour regarder comment est-ce qu'on va
sécuriser les choses de la même manière
si le porteur de l'avs league
le porteur de l'application est déclarée
par un test pcr ou c ou sérologique
comme étant positif
qu'est-ce qu'on a imaginé comme mesure
de pour prévenir ce qu'ils sont cons qui
ont été en contact
un temps suffisant est ce que pour être
très concret est ce que c'est
l'application elle même qui va vous
envoyer un bip sms une notification
disant vous avez été en contact avec
quelqu'un pense aux porteurs du virus
tel jour à telle heure où est ce qu'on
va aller plus loin ses terres qu'on va
avoir
je sais pas si on en est capable
humainement d'ailleurs parce qu'on va
avoir une armée puisque c'est le terme
coréen de personnes qui vont être
capables d'interpréter est donc de 2 de
mettre en oeuvre cette recette c'est ce
contact
alors moi je devienne un département
dans lequel ces choses ont été faites au
niveau des premier cluster qui sont le
store des contamines-montjoie que sort
de la balme de sillingy ou la rs a mis
ça en place alors il n'ya pas
d'application mais on a repris
l'historique des gens dans monsieur et
si vous madame
est-ce qu'elle quelles ont été vos
contacts sociaux les plus proches
pendant ces derniers jours et toutes les
personnes ont été contactées par des
médecins ou par des personnes relevant
de la grèce capable de
dire attention vous avez dentelle car
été en contact avec une personne de sa
famille je mesure en même temps le
l'envergure de cette question qui est
considérable puisque c'est vraiment une
question de moyens humains très
importante
et puis la présence à boussu prend
surprendra pas vous savez que le sénat
est très vigilant aux questions de
souveraineté
on aura l'occasion d'y revenir je pense
demain avec le le ministre de
l'intérieur était sans doute cet après
midi à la question gouvernement il n'y a
pas beaucoup de bonnes nouvelles dans
cette affaire du coronavirus il y en a
une peut-être ya peut-être une
opportunité qui est celle de nos des
entreprises françaises et européennes
capables de mettre en place cette cette
application on déplore souvent
l'inexistence de licorne dans notre pays
dans le domaine du numérique
est ce qu'on est aujourd'hui on risque
d'avoir des solutions clés en main qui
nous sont proposés par google apple dont
je lisais un article du guardian les
anglais parlent de palans tirs est-ce
que de ce côté de l'atlantique dans le
cadre du rejet des entreprises qui
ont la culture de protection des données
personnelles ne devrait pas être
privilégiée
là aussi je jeu la question est très
sensible et très politique j'en ai bien
conscience mais je me dis qu'à l'instant
où on se parle aujourd'hui en commission
des lois du sénat c'est important qu'on
parle de ces questions là parce que
d'avoir des professionnels qui
connaissent notre cadre juridique notre
culture
ce sera beaucoup plus facile d'avoir une
application qui sera finalement
respectueuse de ce que nous voulons que
si nous avons recours à des des des
personnes qui sont des groupes
extrêmement puissant et qui on aurait
peut-être des arrière pensées
avec cette application je vous remercie
merci monsieur président
pour tenter de répondre à monsieur vous
attabler finalement dans l'incitation
mais je suis presque à contre à contre
emploi en quelque sorte en partenaire si
on peut faire valoir et effectivement
comme d'ailleurs ça vient d'être appelé
par le sénateur loïc hervé que ce qu'il
se fait aujourd'hui manuellement en
réalité qui peut prendre deux trois
jours à partir du moment où une personne
est détecté comme étant positive de la
contacter d'essayer de lui demander avec
tous les aléas que la mémoire peut
représenter et et l'imprécision qui peut
être lié avec qui en a été en contact
peut se faire de façon automatisée et
plus rapide
et encore une fois ça n'est qu'un des
éléments vous l'avez très bien souligné
d'une réponse qui doit être plus globale
parce que si c'est soit soit resté
totalement confinés mais évidemment
comme on peu pas confiné toute la
population s'est pas c'est pas l'objet
justement d'une application de ce type
qui viendrait à l'appui d'une stratégie
de déconfinement faut naturellement
pouvoir tester de façon massive mais je
pense encore une fois pendant insistant
beaucoup sur les garanties et la
confiance c'est un facteur incitatif qui
peut être tout à fait important et je
pense aussi c'était une des façons de
répondre de la même façon au sénateur
hervé qu'il est très important que les
autorités de santé continue à jouer tout
leur rôle y compris dans le cadre d'une
application comme celle ci parce que
finalement c'est vrai que comment ça
fonctionne le bluetooth vous téléchargez
l'application le bluetooth une
technologie de proximité
c'est ce qui permet de connecter
éventuellement notre canal 20 pourra
vous en dire plus le cas échéant mais
c'est ce qui permet de connecter des
équipements proximité vos oreillettes
avec votre téléphone votre souris
d'ordinateur et votre ordinateur
donc dans un cercle de proximité proche
de téléphone donc deux utilisateurs qui
ont téléchargé la même application se
voit t'informer alors le côté positif du
bluetooth en termes de protection des
données
c'est que ce sont des données qui sont
chiffrés c'est à dire que vous
téléchargez l'application salle génère
un identifiant à aléatoire qui est
chiffré qui est sûre stockées sur votre
téléphone ce qui en termes de sécurité
est quelque chose de très positif et ça
n'est que lorsqu'une personne a été
détectée positive et qu'elle leur antre
dans l'application que logiquement en
tout cas c'est ce qui s'est passé à
singapour le ministère de la santé où je
l'espère en france une autorité de santé
[Musique]
demanderait à cet utilisateur testés
positifs de lui renvoyer l'historique de
ses contacts et c'est cette autorité qui
ferait le lien entre l'identifiant qui
n'est pas donc nominatifs et un numéro
de téléphone qui n'est pas associée à
une personne donc l'autorité de santé de
ne sait pas à qui appartient le numéro
de téléphone pour l'informer que l a été
en contact avec quelqu'un qui a été
testé positif et ça nous paraît
important effectivement qui est une
autorité de santé après quel sera son
rôle exactement pour pouvoir apprécier
ou non la réalité de l'interaction entre
des individus ça supposerait
effectivement comme vous le soulignez
monsieur le sénateur hervé une
infrastructure extrêmement importante
est ce que ça sera juste de la
l'information en fait mais par une
autorité compétente sur le sujet où
est-ce que ça ira au delà c'est le si
naturellement pas en mesure de répondre
à cette question
et avant de passer peut-être la parole
au secrétaire général adjoint de la cnil
sur les mérites comparés silo dire en
termes d'efficacité du bluetooth et
peut-être de la géolocalisation qui
n'est pas envisagée mais qui permet de
retracer effectivement beaucoup plus
précisément le parcours des uns et des
autres et on voit dans certains pays que
du coup on vous dit dans tel immeuble à
une personne infectée ou ne passait pas
n'allez pas dans ce centre commercial
parce que là il ya eu des cas et c'est
sais pas ce qui est envisagé en france
en ce qui concerne la souveraineté
l e siècle sénat y est très attaché à
cette place même participer à une
audition
une commission d' enquête sur la
souveraineté numérique il ya quelques il
ya il ya quelques temps
en tout cas la sécurité d'une
application comme celle-là c'est un des
éléments de la grille d'analysé du rgp
des la cnil est très engagé sur ces
questions de cybersécurité d'ailleurs le
rg lui donne des compétences en
matière de sécurité on ne connaît pas
assez je trouve ce rôle de la cnil qui
notamment à l'égard des entreprises
enfin deux doit se voir notifier les
notification de violation des données
par exemple et dans un rôle
d'accompagnement et de contrôle fort sur
ces questions avec des demandes analyse
d'impact pour des traitements sur ce
sujet là et c'est en ce qui concerne
l'hébergement différentes solutions
peuvent être envisagées mais le rgpp
prévoit le cas de transfert de données
dont tant que c'est en france ou en
europe
en tout cas on a les moyens soient de
s'assurer nous mêmes de ce qui se passe
concrètement et je pense aussi
dans l'hypothèse qui devrait venir si
cette installation suscite cette
application était installée de la
suppression des données pouvoir vraiment
contrôler physiquement très concrètement
la suppression des données sur un
serveur central par exemple donc soit en
france soit en europe avec l'aide de nos
homologues ça c'est une question
importante ce qui compte c'est qu'on
maîtrise vraiment l' architecture
technique
voilà d'un
un dispositif de ce type qui seraient
mises en place et vous avez évoqué
monsieur le sénateur loïc hervé les
annonces récentes de google et d'apple
sur le sujet on peut se dire que c'est
très positif en tout cas que les deux
entreprises
enfin qu' on bat quasi monopole en tout
cas des téléphones utilisés dans le
monde que ce soit les iphone ou les
smartphones sous android se parlent et
cherche à avoir à faire dialoguer
potentiellement leur téléphone
respectifs entre pour pouvoir échanger
des informations dans l'hypothèse des
dispositifs de suivi des personnes mais
il faut naturellement quand même que ces
sujets soient suivis de très près par
les pouvoirs publics et que dès la
conception de ces réflexions les
préoccupations de protection des données
soit nous soit mise tout à fait en haut
au premier rang des préoccupations et en
même temps je me garderai bien à ce
stade de dire dans quelle mesure ce qui
est envisagé est conforme ou non aux rg
quelles sont les données qui seront
collectés quelles sont les données qui
seront remontés à un serveur central est
ce que sont les données même identifié
même ensemble ceux de nîmes de façon de
se donner miser des personnes exposées
des personnes infectées bon je sais pas
mais peut-être que sur les mérites
comparés du bluetooth et et d'autres
solutions notamment la géolocalisation
peut passer la parole à gwendal le grand
merci à mme la présidente
manque juste juste pour compléter en
effet quoi une des vertus annoncé de
l'application c'est la possibilité de
faciliter aux d'automatiser la recherche
des contacts qu'on a eues par opposition
à une recherche sur la base de sa propre
mémoire le côté positif du bluetooth
c'est le fait qu'on peut faire de la
recherche de quoi on peut détecter de la
proximité avec d'autres utilisateurs
sans avoir recours à un pistage gps de
l'ensemble des localisations de
l'ensemble des individus
donc en fait en réalité vous avez vu
juste besoin de savoir vous avez été à
proximité d'une personne pendant un
certain temps ce qui ne nécessite pas de
géolocaliser les utilisateurs et savoir
précisément où ils se sont trouvés à
proximité
donc c'est en ça que ça a des vertus
vis-à-vis de la protection des données
on peut tout à fait aussi concevoir
l'application pour révéler qui a eu une
proximité à un moment donné donc une
potentielle exposition sans dire
s'est-elle personnes à tel moment qui
vous a exposé donc ça également c'est
quelque chose qui est importante du
point de vue de la protection des
données
on n'a pas besoin de savoir qui nous a
exposé un moment particulier on a juste
besoin de savoir qu'on expose à un
risque pour savoir ensuite comment
réagir donc selon c'est je comprends
très bien que en anonyme is les choses
c'est sans doute d'ailleurs souhaitable
mais ça signifie du point de vue de
l'utilité pratique que celui qui va
recevoir l'information selon laquelle il
a été exposé n'est pas forcément en
mesure de la resituer dans le contexte
vous évoquez madame la présidente le
fait que la personne porte à la personne
qui nous a éventuellement exposé porte
un masque ou non si on ne sait pas à
quelle heure exactement on a été exposée
on ne peut pas évaluer le degré de
dangerosité de cette exposition jeu je
donne simplement guinée mais après en
effet ça doit être croisées avec les
besoins en terme sanitaire pour être
capables de faire ce diagnostic et puis
après la question si c'est une fois que
vous avez une sorte d' alerte dix ans
nous a été potentiellement exposés est
ce qu'on vous informe pour que vous
preniez des mesures barrières le temps
de vous faire tester
est ce que le but c'est de vous rappeler
au téléphone pour vous guider et le cas
échéant en effet également les données
qui vont être tenenbaum pas les mêmes
dans l'application il faut avoir tous
ces éléments en tête donc savoir qu'elle
est également quel est précisément
l'objectif comment l'application doit
fonctionner et en fonction de ça on peut
construire une architecture qui est plus
protectrice des libertés individuelles
l'exemple que je que j'illustrais c'est
par exemple vous pouvez avoir une
une architecture qui est décentralisée
où la liste des contacts rats crs sur le
téléphone est née remontée n'est
échangée qui à partir du moment où vous
êtes diagnostiqués positifs et donc
des faux cils tombe vous resté négatif
si vous voulez les données de contacts
restent sur votre téléphone et donc ne
sont pas partagés donc ça c'est de la
même manière c'est une architecture qui
peut être plus décentralisée en effet en
amont il faut se poser la question du
besoin fonctionnel de l'application pour
savoir comment construire l'application
d'une manière qui va minimiser les
données sur sur apple et google annonce
qui a été faite à ce stade c'est une
annonce un petit pan de temps ou dans un
premier temps il met à disposition ce
qu'on appelle des api donc d'aider des
interfaces qui vont permettre en fait
aux dispositifs de communiquer pour que
ceux qui développent des applications
les autorités qui développent des
applications puissent utiliser ces api
ce qui va permettre une meilleure
interopérabilité des téléphones parce
qu'en effet il s'agit pas qu'un
téléphone de marque apple qui dispose de
l'application n'arrive pas à tracer un
téléphone marc google qui dispose de
l'application également donc ça c'est un
la première étape ils ont dit que dans
un deuxième temps mais sans donner de
date précise
ces possibilités de traçage serait
pourrait être intégré directement dans
les systèmes d'exploitation à l'heure
actuelle on en train de d'étudier ces
questions-là en lien avec nos homologues
au niveau européen puisque évidemment
sont des questions qui également se pose
dans tous les états membres
merci vous n'avez rien a ajouté madame
la présidente sur ce point je vais donc
maintenant donner la parole à cinq de
mes collègues dont je vais dire le nom
pour qu'il se prépare parce que
actuellement ils n'ont ni micros ni
caméras
il s'agit d'abord de monsieur le comte
puy de madame benbassa puis de monsieur
collomb bas puis de monsieur alain
richard s'il de s'il confirme son
souhait puis de madame mercier donc
monsieur le comte
vous avez la parole au niveau bonjour
bonjour chers collègues le bonjour merci
monsieur le président pour cette pour
cette audition
j'avais quelques quelques questions
sachant que la manière dont les
explications que vous avez entendu
jusqu'à présent vous plutôt tendance à
m'inquiéter
dans la mesure où tourner malheureux de
la cnil c'est finalement dans un cadre
de ce type de nous présenter avantages
inconvénients pour qu'ensuite le
politique puisse décider de l'usagé ou
non de cette nouvelle solution technique
alors là j'ai l'impression que la cnil
nous explique comment on pourrait avoir
une application qui serait conforme à
l'air gpd ni plus ni moins alors j'ai
quelques questions par rapport à ça
d'abord bien entendu si on met en place
ce genre de deux dispositions de rats
aussi des stratégies d'évitement
mais est ce qu'on peut ce qu'on peut
nous préciser parce que pour moi le
bluetooth sait lire au téléphone c'est
pas mieux aux nues mais c'est lyon l
appareil ces paliers au numéro de
téléphone donc est-ce que vous pouvez
nous dire si l'application telle qu'elle
est envisagée traque les téléphones
l'appareil ou les numéros ou les deux
qu'est ce qui est prévu
deuxièmement on nous dit bluetooth c'est
moins intrusif que gps mais en réalité
si à quelques endroits stratégiques
on place des téléphones
à des endroits qu'on connaît finalement
on a construit des bornes géolocalisant
tu de passage des personnes
indirectement avec avec ce dispositif
est ce que la cnil troisième question
est ce que la cnil a déjà eu à traiter
des fichiers qui ont été construits sur
la base de données obtenue par bluetooth
si oui est-ce que vous avez une
expérience en la matière ou est ce que
ce sera une nouveauté à bâtir de
volontariat vous nous dites il faut que
ce soit volontaire on imagine bien des
structures privées des salles des
entreprises mais peut-être aussi des
collectivités locales qu'il voudrait
pour la sécurité sanitaire imposé que
toutes les personnes qui qui rentre à
tel ou tel ou tel lieu puisse bénéfices
avoir fait avoir cette application qui
pourrait sanctionner de telles démarches
de conditionnalité est ce que c'est la
cnil est ce qu'il faudrait que ce soit
prévu dans la loi
quand vous nous parlez de l'air gpd au
niveau européen
elle peut aller encore plus loin parce
que nous avons déjà des pays européens
qui ont rendu obligatoire des
applications géolocalisant dans le cadre
de la pandémie alors la rgpp le permet
est ce que la cnil elle pourrait aller
jusque là enfin en ce qui concerne les
finalités
on sait bien on l'a vu sur d'autres
fichiers qu'une fois qu'on a construit
un fichier et que certains se rendent
compte que pour des finalités d'ordre
public de sécurité sanitaire et on l'a
déjà vu pour l'ordre public
il faut changer la finalité on change la
finalité est ce que vraiment sur une
application de cette nature ou peut se
permettre de prendre ce risque
c'est à dire de construire un fichier
dont on sait après que la finalité
pourrait être détournée je remercie
merci beaucoup chers collègues
la parole est maintenant à madame esther
benbassa
merci monsieur le nous entendons chers
collègues vous m'entendez pas si très
bien bonjour je reconnais chers
collègues
bonjour si on me donnait la parole
bonjour à tout le monde madame la
présidente
ne craignez-vous pas que les potentiels
malades
avec cette application soit incité à
cacher leurs symptômes aux services de
santé de peur de conséquences négatives
en même temps l'envers de la médaille
serait que les personnes qui ont cette
application est le sentiment disons de
gentiment un faux sentiment de sécurité
et l'application à l'opium en
l'occurrence pourrait inciter à réduire
les gestes barrières tout en échouant à
lancer des allègres suffisamment fiable
deuxièmement elle vous avait déjà fait
allusion à l'anonymat mais l'objectif de
cette application c'est d'alerter les
personnes donc par essence
elle est incompatible avec la notion
juridique d'anonymat pourriez vous nous
donner quelques éléments dans ce centre
je vous remercie
merci beaucoup cher collègue monsieur
pierre yves collombat
oui bonjour a tous entendu oui chers
collègues bonjour merci bonjour madame
la présidente madame la présidente
d'intervention il ya un point qui m'a
particulièrement intéressé c'est quand
plus vous êtes revenu par des biais
différence avant la des occasions
différentes c'est cesser ceci c'est que
en fait pour vous et je trouve ça je te
fais d'accord avec avec ce point de vue
il n'y a pas de décision technique qui
soient pertinentes
indépendamment de la connaissance d'une
foule d'autres paramètres d'une autre
nature que technique par un maître
médicaux bien évidemment sociologique
les moyens humains les moyens les moyens
financiers industriels enfin et c'est ça
ressort de différentes interventions se
la question voulez vous posez c'est est
ce qu'il existe à votre connaissance une
instance l'organisme enfin en tout cas
au moins un lieu de coordination de des
différentes obligations des uns et des
autres et où ces échanges peuvent se
faire ailleurs que que dans la presse je
trouve que ces errements des aspects les
plus les plus critiquables de notre
organisation c'est que tout le monde
dans son coin
la meilleure volonté du monde et les
moyens qu'il a essaye de trouver des
solutions
mais est-ce qu'il serait pas judicieux
de pouvoir de mettre en place un
dispositif qui permettent de confronter
les points de vue et de déboucher sur
des solutions aurait toutes les chances
d'être d'être efficaces et respectueux
bien sûr des libertés et qui permettrait
vraiment d'avancé sur la question merci
chers collègues vous avez terminé votre
question oui merci beaucoup je donne la
parole à madame marie mercier
donc bonjour je vous entends dans ce jeu
je voulais vous remercier pour cet
exposé extrêmement clair nous ont bien
compris qu'en fait la question elle
porte sur le caractère utile nécessaire
proportionnée mais surtout temporaire du
tracking ce qui fera qu'avec toutes ces
garanties effectivement on tracera un
cadre de confiance mais ensuite comment
est-on sûr que ce ce côté temporaire
sera bien mis en place est-ce qu'on est
véritablement sûr que ces informations
seront effacées supprimés et durablement
est ce que ceci est véritablement
possible je vous remercie
merci beaucoup cher collègue madame la
présidente
merci monsieur président et merci en
tout cas pour toutes ces questions en ce
qui concerne la question où les
questions du sénateur le compte
très très clairement si c'est une
application fondée sur le bluetooth ça
n'est pas de la géolocalisation on a vu
que dans un certain nombre de pays
effectivement il y avait un mix il peut
me permettre cette expression entre
différentes technologies c'est pas du
tout ce qui est annoncé dans
l'application telle qu'elle est et ce
qui s'est donc il ne s'agit pas de
données gps et qui permettent de tracer
très précisément de retracer très
précisément le parcours d'un individu
voilà ça n'est pas du tout le cas avec
du
bluetooth alors est ce que la cnil a
l'expérience de fichiers ou de
technologies de ce type
oui elle a notamment je pense mais il
sera possible de développer davantage si
vous souhaitez en ce qui concerne les
gestions de files d'attentes dans les
aéroports de panneaux publicitaires
aussi en tout cas on peut développer ce
point le cas échéant passait pas une
technologie qui nous est inconnu ni la
question du traitement des données dans
ce cadre là
c'est à dire des panneaux publicitaires
c'est quoi pour combien de personnes
peuvent éventuellement voir des panneaux
publicitaires quand on passe devant de
façon à tenir sans pouvoir mesurer cette
audience sans pour autant retracer
identifier la personne qui qui qui est
passé devant et puis peut-être la
dernière question de monsieur le comte
elle me paraît tout à fait important
pour qu'il y ait pas d'ambiguïté sur le
rôle de la cnil
quand on se demande si la cnil pourrait
aller au delà et c'est ça n'est pas la
cnil très concrètement qui décident de
la mise en oeuvre de ce dispositif et
neil en tant que gardienne numériques
indépendantes de la vie privée des
français elle est là précisément pour
veiller si un dispositif de ce type
étaient mises en oeuvre à ce que
suffisamment de garanties soient
apportées pour que
les données personnelles soient protégés
de la meilleure des façons
alors en ce qui concerne la question de
madame benbassa sur l'anonymat est ce
vraiment de l'anonymat c'est plus
précisément l'anonymat c'est plutôt dans
l'hypothèse effectivement d'une
agrégation de données telles qu'elles
finissent par être anonymisées sont par
exemple les solutions flûte vision
d'orange ou de sfr qui ont pour objet
plutôt de cartographier la propagation
de l'épidémie pour pouvoir apporter une
réponse sanitaire là il s'agit de
lorsque vous téléchargez l'application
qu'un pseudonyme
soit soient générés ce qui est très
important en la matière c'est la raison
pour laquelle au sens commun du terme ça
peut rejoindre l'idée d'un anonymat
c'est qu'il n'y ait pas de ré
identification possible de la personne
ça c'est le point absolument essentiel
qu'on puisse parer identifier la
personne
si vous souhaitez qu'on complète ce pont
pourra certainement le faire
et en tout cas telle qu'elle est conçue
aujourd'hui telle qu'elle a été conçue à
singapour
finalement sont mises en relation un
identifiant qui n'est donc pas une
donnée nominative c'est pas le nom de
quelqu'un avec in fine et un numéro de
téléphone et et la mise en relation se
fait sans que la personne qui fait la
mise en relation ou sache à qui
appartient ce numéro de téléphone donc
de fait il ne doit pas y avoir et ça
c'est un élément tout à fait essentiel
effectivement dorée identification
possible de la personne voilà ça c'est
sûr sur ce point là sur la question du
sénateur collombat sur la nécessité
d'une instance de coordination pour
obliger les uns et les autres à se
communiquer en tout cas ce que je
constate et d'une certaine façon c'est à
la hauteur de la vigueur de
l'attachement que les français ont pour
les libertés constate quand même la
vigueur du débat en france sur le
concept même de cette application est
sur son éventuelle mise en oeuvre je ne
crois pas que ça soit le cas dans un
certain nombre d'autres pays d'après ce
que j'ai cru comprendre donc en tout cas
les français sont attachés à leur
liberté le débat a lieu et les autorités
chacune dans leur rôle respectif se
coordonnent nous nous avons par exemple
un partenariat de longue date avec
l'inria qui est aujourd'hui l'institut
de recherche nationale qui coordonne les
initiatives dans ce domaine en liaison
avec des partenaires européens notamment
suisses et allemands nous sommes très
impliqués aussi
dans
ces réflexions encore une fois avec le
seul prisme en ce qui nous concerne ce
qui est normal parce que c'est notre
rôle de privilégier les solutions qui
sont les plus protectrices de la vie
privée nous sommes sans lien avec le
secrétariat d'état au numérique
le parlement a naturellement un rôle
très important à jouer par des auditions
un débat voilà où en tout cas sur toutes
les formes qui souhaiteraient
privilégier
donc il me semble que la coordination en
tout cas entre les différentes autorités
compétentes
ce
ce fait maintenant il faudra
naturellement qu'en termes de contrôle
aussi si cette application voit le jour
et c'est peut-être plus le sens encore
de la question du sénateur colombes à
toutes les autorités concernées puissent
vraiment effectivement être associés en
premier lieu la cnil naturellement parce
que c'est ça sa mission même de
contrôler la mise en oeuvre d'un
dispositif de ce type est de s'assurer
notamment que les données sont
supprimées par exemple mais aussi
d'autres l'ansi pour la sécurité des
systèmes d'information d'autres d'autres
autorités
le contrôle du parlement bien entendu
voilà donc ça c'est peut-être
effectivement en matière de contrôle
notamment qu'il faut qu'il y ait une
coordination particulièrement forte sur
la question de madame mercier sur le
caractère temporaire du dispositif est
effectivement je je soulignerai aussi
parce que je n'ai pas du tout dit que il
nous paraît important qu'on puisse
également d installer cette application
en quelque sorte ça rejoint aussi un peu
la question du consentement on peut
l'installer certes en étant tout à fait
éclairé et informer et avec un acte
positif mais il faut aussi pouvoir la
désinstaller en fait ça ça paraît
important et c'est un petit lien avec le
caractère temporaire mais la question de
la dame mercier naturellement visait
plus largement la fin me semble-t-il de
ce dispositif
il faut vraiment effectivement se garder
que des dispositifs exceptionnels pris
dans des circonstances exceptionnelles
puisse perdurer
on a vu qu'il peut y avoir une tendance
lorsque des mesures d'urgence ont adopté
à ce qu'elle soit
prolonger voire introduite dans le droit
commun un moment ou à un autre il pareil
froid qu'il faut être extrêmement
vigilant sur ce plan d'autant plus qu'il
peut y avoir une sorte de banalisation
en quelque sorte de l'utilisation de ces
technologies auprès de ses utilisateurs
donc il faut que la durée de ces d'une
application de ce type ne dépasse
vraiment pas le temps qui est
strictement nécessaire pour juguler la
crise et d'autre part la cnil a
l'habitude de s'assurer que des données
ont été supprimés et elle l'a fait par
exemple sur enfin sur différents
fichiers elle est tout à fait capable de
se rendre sur place et de s'assurer in
situ que les données sont supprimées au
moment où elles doivent l'être
voilà je sais pas s'il ya des points de
complément le cas échéant aussi à
d'autres questions peut-être il va y
avoir de question donc pour compléter
très rapidement sur la question de nous
tous et de l'expérience de la cnil en
matière bluetooth et une technologie qui
n'est pas nouvelle le bluetooth intégrés
dans des équipements que vous avez dans
vos poches depuis quand même un certain
nombre d'années et c'est utilisé comme
l'a dit la présidente
dans un certain nombre de dispositifs de
mesure d'audience ou de mesures de
fréquentation des espaces accessibles au
public pour regarder par exemple le
temps que vous passez dans une file d
attente ou des choses comme ça où la
houle à la fréquentation d'un d'un
dispositif publicitaire
donc en réalité le bluetooth et une
carte réseau qui est dans votre
téléphone qui est un identifiant
particulier qui va être détectées par
l'autre appareil bluetooth qui à
proximité donc ce n'est pas basée sur
votre nom votre prénom et s'est pas
basée sur votre téléphone
après rien n'empêche en effet que
l'application soit conçu de telle
manière que d'autres informations sont
envoyées mais pour la pure détection de
la proximité bluetooth cd identifiant
qui sont des dix identifiant les ide
liés à la carte réseau bluetooth qui est
dans votre équipement qui vont être
échangés
peut-être ai-je été inattentif sans que
n'ait pas répondu à la question des
sanctions des entreprises par exemple
qui mettrait en oeuvre des procédures
qui porterait atteinte à la liberté de
leurs salariés par l'exigence qui le
recours à cette éventuelle application
et madame benbassa insistait sur
plusieurs questions dont la question de
l'anonymat que j'ai approché tout à
l'heure selon la nature de l'information
qui va être apportée aux bénéficiaires
du dispositif sur le fait qu'il aura été
exposés à un risque parce qu'il a été en
contact avec une personne pendant un
certain temps si l'horaire ou le lieu
sont indiquer la date précise
il sera aisé de pour ces personnes de
reconstituer quelle est la personne
contaminée qui justifie que l'alertent
lui soit donnée est donc dans la
configuration du dispositif
et si on veut maintenir l'anonymat il
faut penser non seulement la d'anima de
la personne qui reçoit la formation mais
aussi vis-à-vis de cette personne à
l'anonymat de la personne source
éventuelle delà de la contamination est
évidemment c'est une question très
délicate
merci beaucoup chers collègues je vais
donner la parole à madame denis non sans
lui avoir posé une ultime question
madame la présidente
connaissez-vous maintenant le calendrier
de la saisine de la cnil par le
gouvernement sur un projet de dispositif
et avez vous déjà reçu des informations
précises sur ce qu'envisagerait de faire
le gouvernement
sur cette dernière question monsieur le
président nous n'avons pas reçu un
projet en tout cas finaliser le
déconfinement
étant programmée à partir du 11 mai j'ai
cru comprendre que le gouvernement
souhaiterait à partir de la mi-mai
savoir si prend effectivement une
décision de ce type parce que la
décision en tout cas ce qui a été dit
n'est pas arrêté ici une décision de ce
type doit être prise début mais nous
sommes ni avril il est temps
effectivement que la cnil soit saisie
dès que cela sera possible des modalités
précises de ce dispositif
il nous faut au minimum me semble-t-il
une semaine et plus on aura de temps
mieux ce sera parce qu'il faut
concrètement qu on puisse analyser le
dispositif que le collège de la cnil
puisse en prendre
connaissances et suffisamment de temps
pour en prendre connaissance et que vous
ayez le pont nous ayons le temps d'en
débattre
et puis après comme puissions rendre un
avis
et qui peut demander un petit peu de
temps matière de rédaction en fonction
de ce que va décider le collège donc une
semaine me paraît être un grand grand
minimum
voilà pour répondre à votre question sur
les sanctions
la cnil a une grande habitude de la
pratique des sanctions à l'égard des
entreprises ou des organismes publics ça
peut passer soit par des mises en
demeure soit par des injonctions soi
même par des sanctions financières mais
ce qui serait moins approprié là me
semble-t-il mais en tout état de cause
quand la cnil peut prendre des sanctions
extrêmement rapidement elle a un service
des plaintes très développée elle a des
dizaines de contrôleurs à la fois des
juristes mais des techniciens une
formation restreinte indépendante une
sorte de commission des sanctions qui
peut se réunir rapidement dans le cadre
d'une procédure contradictoire
naturellement donc ça il n'y a pas de
difficultés et moi même le en tant que
présidente de la cnil j'ai la
possibilité de mettre en demeure un
organisme public par exemple ou une
entreprise et le bureau de la tille avec
deux autres membres du collège latine
nous pouvons rendre publique cette mise
en demeure le caseyeur donc il ya des
moyens juridiques qu'on pratique tout à
fait régulièrement pour faire respecter
le cadre juridique en ce qui concerne
l'anonymat est la question de madame
benbassa la question que vous avez
prolongé monsieur le président je n'ai
pas compris que dans le dispositif
encore une fois que je l'entends je n'ai
pas connaissance
il y aurait la possibilité d'avoir
l'horaire et le lieu de la personne
contaminée qu'on aurait rencontré et
donc effectivement de savoir si on a été
va caler le risque réel d'exposition que
l'on a eues mais mais ça sous réserve de
l'architecturé qui pourraient être tenus
mais je ne pense pas mais effectivement
la question n'est pas là même si vous
avez croisé quatre personnes dans une
commune rurale depuis quinze jours et
vous recevez une alerte en termes de
régimes anti fication ou si vous êtes
dans une grande ville et que vous prenez
les transports en commun l'art et
identification est naturellement plus
difficile alors la question de monsieur
kerrouche
[Musique]
sur google et apple
en tout cas le comité européen de la
protection des données les cnil
européennes n'ont pas du tout donné
blanc seing de satisfecit ou prononcé
qu'au quoi que ce soit en ce qui
concerne cette initiative d'apple et
google
est ce que c'est à juste titre monsieur
qu'est rouge c'est un une prise de
position de le dps qui est le contrôleur
la protection des données des instances
européennes en fait de l'union
européenne
et eux
effectivement s'il est positif que deux
entreprises qui comme le dit monsieur
pierrot chante un quasi duopole sur les
téléphones qu'il s'assurait que dans le
cadre d'une application de ce type et
via bluetooth un skate avis et bien été
précisée par apple et google
les téléphones puisse est interopérable
et dialoguer il faut naturellement que
en matière de protection des données
tout ça soit analysé qu'on en sache plus
et que ça reste tout à fait une solution
en tout cas ponctuels il est lié à la
crise madame la présidente monsieur je
vous remercie infiniment de votre
contribution à la réflexion du sénat sur
ces questions qui sont infiniment
complexe et pour lesquels nous sommes
maintenant mieux éclairer nous allons
continuer nos investigations dans un
instant avec le professeur delfraissy
et je vais donc suspendre vous
remerciant de nouveau la séance pour
cinq minutes
voilà pour cette audition de marie laure
denis
la présidente de la cnil la commission
nationale de l'informatique et des
libertés qui s'est donc exprimé devant
les sénateurs de la commission des lois
qui a largement pointé les limites du
projet d'application stop qu'ovide qui
en tout cas ne pourrait être qu'un outil
dans le cadre du déconfinement
permettant de savoir si l'on a croisé
dans les jours précédents une personne
porteuse du coc vide
en tout cas la stratégie de
déconfinement ne pourra pas s'en tenir
simplement à cette application vous
pouvez toujours voir et revoir toutes
les auditions sur notre site
publicsenat.fr
très bonne journée sur les chaînes
parlementaires
[Musique]